à magny les hameaux ce midi au menu pour
les enfants rient chou fleur et viande
bien loin de celle caoutchouteuse chanté
par carlos en 1972 depuis 2011 la
commune a choisi de passer au bio pour
les 90 % d'élèves scolarisés déjeunant à
la cantine on a voulu passer à avoir une
restauration de qualité et 50 % de bio
donc ça veut dire un produit laitier
donc à chaque chaque repas et soit la
viande soit le poisson soit le
un légume enfin après le deuxième
produit au choix de sodexo puisque c'est
ce dax au qui a remporté le marché à
cette époque du bio mais aussi du
circuit court les laitages comme les
yaourts ou les fromages viennent de
fermer au call comme celle de victhom de
jouer en josas et de coubertin à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse favoriser les
circuits courts pour notamment
sensibiliser au goût redonner du goût
c'est aussi l'objectif de trappes
la commune a choisi d'avoir une cuisine
centrale pour produire chaque jour 2000
repas pour ses cantines pour maîtriser
entièrement toute la chaîne de
fabrication pour maîtrisez également les
produits de base qui sont transformés et
savoir ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette de
l'enfant la qualité bio c'est déjà un
label reconnu
même si tout n'est pas parfait dans le
bio il ya quand même une avancée
positive intéressante à poursuivre et
aujourd'hui nous arrivons à avoir des
menus entier composé de bio et parfois
dans le mois
des matières des matières comme les
yaourts et fromages entièrement bio
fabriqués dans le département plus d'un
million d'euros de budget est consacré
par la commune à la cuisine centrale
chaque jour les 13 membres de l'équipe
arrive à 7 heures pour préparer le repas
des 30 office près de 780 kg de produits
sont cuisinés des produits issus
principalement du circuit court et bio
en fonction des saisons
tous les produits sont réceptionnés
entre deux et trois jours avant la date
de production
nous produisons le matin nos
conditionnements
donc nous sommes dans en liaison froide
donc une production nous cuisons nous
refroidit leçon
avec les normes donc
les normes d'hygiène nous mettons en
barquettes et livrons le
le matin pour le midi donc des repas qui
sont fabriqués la veille trappe souhaite
aussi que l'enfant puisse choisir ce
qu'ils mangent pour cette rentrée la
commune propose dans des écoles pilotes
un double choix pour le plat chaud